welcome to this video pitted corporate
BTW capri I don't know so yeah I
remember oh I thought I thought he was a
king's indian layer for some for some
reason he reduces the nation andreas
play readers yeah so we get them the
same ish variation
angling for 40 interesting okay i think
i go here to have 90 f 21 queen edge for
that's an interesting way of playing for
that quick f5 so we for now yeah i think
i have then have to is a bit strong but
close to if you go see five himself
that's no good so let's push
I won't ever should go in five if he
gets to play you five that's really
annoying so let's do that takes I wanted
to go Queenie to maybe this is an it's a
bit dicey but I have to play actively
here okay taking Boston wasn't the idea
yeah maybe just see five forward if it
takes on d4 I go see six Bishop takes
Queen e6 and then Quincy six maybe maybe
okay Queen to f6 I can go here for a
quick phone I g4 yeah that looks okay I
would like to have this night phone 495
ideas but didn't didn't really work out
maybe I could have gone night before my
g4 played a bit quick but too quickly
here okay mia has to go to have seven i
guess and flick this in now 55 that is
very likely okay for black so 95 I my
cheek so let's do this and night takes I
got 95 and at least that is a good well
positioned night okay no that's that's
not so bad I'm a pawn down I didn't see
that that's funny I thought as equal
material so this is why I'm not minding
to trade but i'm born down that's good
to know i really didn't see that okay
cool it's not full compensation but I've
seen worse positions
let's see easy fam two coordinators
pieces I'm quite active yeah I thought
after Bishop seat we just has to go back
or I don't know where is he going to be
five maybe
yeah anyway
yeah so is there anything a for Brooke
cakes no bishop is immediately hanging
that's not good
hmm no really good enough available
24 he goes okay Queen have six i can go
queen 84 it's not so bad just didn't see
that move coming
Scott Bishop c4 so I have to take note
of that I mean of course I fh seven
currently under fire but and it's got
Queen Queen wage for bit could Kim Ji
Won yeah I'm still kind of hanging on
here third for Bishop perform
queen bee to maybe yep
I played that well really didn't I
didn't I will looked many of his moves
and
should be four
I can just take stuff can you even take
a three no I wanted to check with the
Queen which of course it's nonsense my
rook is hanging so i can check though
and quince you fall on something like
that check I can also ever and more
checks actually queen bee to check and
then checking one of eight that's not
helping check on c3 maybe island then
then it's got this one coming look the
7s covered so that's no good push-up f8
no time morning let's do something crazy
yeah now I have this check and Queen f3
check check Knight f6 d500 force my idea
it's got you know it's got checks check
I just got to check on CT Quincy don't
check check check what a crazy position
but does he have anything better than
Queen f5 I don't just be it at the
moment so I got this I got this piece
and I'm not seeing how i'm getting chick
mated don't like that maybe scott cool
check check check black forfeits on time
i type resort 0 as well what was that
and how quick i mean how quick did he
play at the end I mean time wise i was
totally winning 21 verses for here yeah
it took a moment there because i felt i
could have could be checkmated yeah that
was very undeserved but really really
outplayed him well this was a big mess
I'm not sure about this if this was so
bad oh wow Queen situ and wide wins this
is surprising why why am i winning
age 6 I didn't look at the move at all
that wasn't the idea though why am i
winning here the check funny no then 96
wins what does win bishop g six wins
okay yeah well okay this is indeed
really bad because i get f for ya ok and
here computer just takes and then i can
I am threatening to take edge five-track
take f4 with the night wow that's cool
and there is this idea it's really a
cool idea Queen f2 letting the shine
night on age five being on the room and
up for the taking huh funny nah ok my
idea was just to activate I didn't
really see anything like that get here
I'm the spawn down but I really felt I
should be okay again Quincy to a strong
now I never had this on the agenda
somehow and Quincy to was a good move
again and I didn't see that why are you
Bishop b2 is given by the engine with an
advantage for white even though i have
two points down but it looks like some
play but two pawns is to pawn some
hmm okay then it's almost impossible to
play like that yeah Lucas is 60 for this
is the computer line and now it gives
Knight f6 returning upon which means
that what about let's let's play some
move what is the issue 85 black just
sits rugby one yeah okay I see ya we
should be the a5 is because this is a
move and now I'm threatening this Andrew
piayed now yeah it is pretty strong that
I did I really did play it well then
okay i can take age seven here oh
because of the Hanging Rock won't be
five yeah so really a bad game made many
mistakes in and didn't exploit
opportunities yeah yeah I simply hitting
wanted to take with the queen of course
check now I went to g4s the best move
hmm i found that and here i'm winning
with queen of three winning okay queen
of a checkmate very strong okay now
didn't see that one now I didn't see
that one I only saw said check this is
happening but Shaq just gonna take this
win how would be three wins for him I
didn't see that he's got 10 seconds left
will be three
check check yeah it's here Danna know
why I should win nope it's okay at the
time I mean he really really made tons
of moves with this three seconds amazing
yeah there was a funny game thanks for
watching